Let me know if this has
ever happened to you-- where
you have this brilliant idea of
an app that you want to build,
and all you want to do is run
home and start working on it.
As you start building
it, though, you quickly
realize you need a
back end or a server
in the cloud to really
demonstrate the full idea.
And so you fire up a
browser and start searching.
How do you build a back end
server for a mobile or web app?
Well, it turns out you get
over a million search results
with all sorts of articles
and discussion threads.
And it can be
overwhelming to figure out
how to integrate all of
these technologies together.
But the good news is that
a lot of the complexity
is handled for you with
Google Cloud Endpoints.
It has a
straightforward workflow
so you can build a shared back
end for your Android, iOS,
and web clients.
Previously, I was an engineer
on the Google Keep team
and was exposed to
the issues that I'll
be talking about today,
with building a new product
with multiple clients
accessing a back end.
And that's why I want to
help you get your service up
and running as
quickly as possible.
On the server, you
simply define your API
and add Cloud
Endpoint annotations.
There's an awesome tool
to automatically generate
the client libraries
that you can
drop into your respective apps.
You implement the client
code to call your API
and the server side logic with
what to do an API is called.
And then everything
else in between
is handled by Cloud Endpoints.
Over time, your server
API will naturally evolve.
And that's where Cloud
Endpoints can really
help reduce those accidental
errors, because it
automatically generates the
client libraries for you.
When you're ready to release the
clients with your latest build,
we'll help you handle
the upgrade smoothly.
Now, this is made
possible by API burgeoning
support in Cloud Endpoints.
Different API versions
can actually coexist,
and you can do a gradual stage
roll out of these new changes.
In this example, new clients
can start to talk to the V2 API
while your order
clients slowly move over
until you deprecate
the old V1 API.
I also want to note that the
back end server that we're
talking about is actually
running on Google App
Engine, which is part of the
broader Google Cloud Platform.
Not only do you get a shared
back end for your Android iOS
and web clients,
but you can also
take advantage of all the
other products and services
that are available.
With App Engine
comes the ability
to actually scale very easily.
As you get more traffic,
Google automatically
spins up more App Engine
instances for you.
And then when the traffic
levels off after the peak,
we kill off the instances
that you don't need any more.
You don't need to
trouble yourself
with estimating resources needs
ahead of time, so it's great.
As an added bonus,
Cloud Endpoints
comes with web management tools,
such as this API Explorer,
which allows you to interact
with all of your API endpoints.
As seen here, you
can create a request
and then see what
the response is.
If you want a
bird's eye overview
of how healthy the service is
for the actual users out there,
on the dashboard,
you can check graphs
with QPS, latency,
and error rates.
You also have access to the logs
if you want more detailed data.
But enough about development.
What type of impact can
Cloud Endpoints really
have on your users?
Well, users expect the
app to be blazing fast,
without those loading
spinners that spin forever.
It's not ideal if you have a
user halfway across the world
and they're trying to
hit the server that's
located in your basement.
Instead, you can take
advantage of Google's
global infrastructure.
We have data centers
all over the world
and we can route requests to
the appropriate data center
quickly.
Now, users also care about
minimizing network usage,
which impacts
their bill, as well
as they want to
minimize battery usage.
Therefore, once we
serialize the data,
we compress it for efficient
transfer across the network.
Now, we know, also,
users want peace of mind
that their data is being
kept and transferred
as securely as possible.
So all of our requests
are sent over HTTPS.
And we also have OAuth
2.0 support built in
to authenticate and
authorize the users
to access the appropriate data.
So as you can see,
Google Cloud Endpoints
is a straightforward way for
you to build a shared back end
for your Android,
iOS, and web clients.
And if you have that
browser still open,
you can search for Google
Cloud Endpoints now.
Or you can use the links here.
Next time you have that great
idea, now you know what to do.